>> SOME OF THE WORST OF THE
FIGHTING IS IN EASTERN UKRAINE,
FOR RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE
UNLEASHED AND RELENTLESS
BARRAGE OF ARTILLERY FOR
MONTHS.
THIS PART OF MOSCOW'S PUSH TO
CAPTURE THE ENTIRE DONBAS
REGION.
DESPITE THE CONSTANT FIGHTING
THE, FRONT LINES OF BRIGHT MOOD
FOR WEEKS.
THE RESIDENTS LIVING NEARBY,
THE THREAT OF DEATH IS NEVER
FAR AWAY.
CNN'S NICK ROBERTSON HAS MORE.
INSTEAD ASK, CIVILIANS ARE
BURIED WHERE THEY FALL, NO TIME,
NO SAFETY FOR A CEMETERY
SENDOFF.
NO BOMB TOO BIG, THEY ARE
BUILDING IN THIS EASTERN
UKRAINIAN TOWN SEEMINGLY OFF
RUSSIA'S TARGET LIST IN THEIR
SLOW BUT RELENTLESS PUSH
WESTWARDS.
>> THIS TOWN IS UNDER THE
FRINGES FOR THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT CONTROLS.
THEY ARE SURROUNDED ON TWO
SIDES BY RUSSIAN FORCES TO THE
EAST AND TO THE NORTH, ABOUT
500 --
FIVE MILES OR TEN KILOMETERS
AWAY.
SHELLING HERE, AND EVER-PRESENT
DANGER.
AMONG THE RUINS, PEOPLE ARE
SURVIVING.
2000 OF A PREWAR, 11 DOZEN
CLINGING ON.
FOR THE AREA, BARELY SEEMS TO
NOTICE SOME OF THE SHELL
EXPLODING.
HOW HARD IS IT TO LIVE HERE NOW?
>> [INTERPRETER]
I DON'T REALIZE IT, BUT SHE'S
ABOUT TO TEACH ME HOW HARD --
>> SHE'S NOT GETTING, SHE COMES
BACK WITH THIS OR ANY FLOOR
BORIS CABBAGE FROM A BURNT
BUILDING.
EVERY DAY.
>> EVERY DAY, SO THIS IS HARD.
GOOD MUSCLES, WHY DO YOU STAY
HERE?
IF IT IS SO HARD, BODIES DAY?
>> VALERIA'S LESSON FOR ME, YES,
LIFE HERE IS VERY HARD, BUT
THIS IS HOME AND LEAVING WOULD
BE HARDER.
>> MY HOUSE, WHILE.
>> BUT YOU DO SO TO USE?
THERE ARE BOMBS AND EXPLOSIONS.
>> SO NICE THIS DAY, SHE SAYS.
WE GO IN THE BASEMENT WHEN
THERE IS SHELLING.
>> SHE LEAVES TO SEE THE
BASEMENT.
>> SO YOU ARE SLEEPING IN HERE,
YOU'RE LIVING ON HERE?
>> WE HAVE BEEN SLIPPING DOWN
HERE FOR MORE THAN THREE MONTHS,
SHE SAYS.
DOWN HERE, HER CHEERFUL SPARKLE
IS GONE.
WE HAD NO GAS, ELECTRICITY,
WATER OR COMMUNICATIONS, SHE
SAYS.
I HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
THERE IS MORE SHE WANTS TO SHOW
US.
>> LOOK AT THIS, SMASHED --
>> VALERIA'S NEIGHBORS, LIKE
HER, COOKING OUTSIDE.
SHE HAS BROUGHT ME TO WHAT IS
LEFT OF OUR FRIENDS.
>> IT'S ALL DESTROYED.
PEOPLE HERE, THEY SURVIVE?
>> GOD SAVE THEM, SHE SAYS, BUT
NOT A LEFT.
>> BY LOCAL STANDARDS, THE
SHELLING THIS DAY LESS THAN
USUAL.
THIS ELDERLY LADY VENTURING OUT
FOR FOOD.
SHE TELLS US THE FOOD AND SHE
NEEDS HAS NOT ARRIVED.
THE SHELLING GETTING CLOSER WE
GO.
NOT SO LUCKY, THOSE WHO BEHIND.
NIC ROBERTSON, CNN, SIVERSK, UKRAINE